what's up everybody Mary here with my
good buddy Mike hey how's it going good
let's play some Resident Evil yeah okay
so I was in this storage room when we
last left off if you guys are joining us
we were playing through all the Resident
Evil starting with one remake remaster
yeah so this is the first day for
meeting it - that's right you also I
found this like cool little box
I put some stuff in it I put this emblem
in it I put that blue gemstone in it it
gave me more magazine I was thinking
right now actually I'm gonna I'll keep
all that stuff in there well I would
hand mitt handgun magazines I would
recommend just you can pick them all
yeah you might as well I mean you're not
gonna you shouldn't need those but I'm
you'll find a lot more like you'll
you'll finish the game with like a
hundred and handgun rounds not me I'm
gonna shoot everything I would say for
the purposes of it you're in your first
playthrough I would say don't bring the
knife it's not I mean you have to be
pretty I would just say help if they
come up behind me and I can stab them in
the face
no no so that's a dagger those are
different oh right so I understand we
mean those batteries later first stun
gun I do defensive items I understand
I'm gonna combine here just like you
taught me
mmm-hmm anything else I should do before
we leave mmm yeah just like for the sake
of clarity examine this key flip around
yeah press X so now which is called a
sword keys to the doors with a sword on
and you'll open hill just so what the
ideal thing to do when you get a new key
in this game is do a minute
well that but also use all the doors as
quickly as possible that you can use it
on so then when you're done with it
it'll say there's no more use do you
want to discard it and won't take up
space your inventory okay so I would say
that's a priority right now wait I only
have six slots so I don't want to be
late but yeah oh right yeah oh oh also
yeah okay so I know what you want to do
right now okay I'm gonna key I didn't
explore down here yeah I would say down
this hallway and then up those stairs
again there's a dude up there though
yes painting of the man Theon oh I hear
it no you're fine you're probably good I
can hear it
I hear the footsteps [ __ ] it oh we did
go down this hallway once before but
it's been a while where's my map Oh
actually shoot okay let me see you so
I'm
going towards these doors but these
doors are locked they're both marked red
yes I believe that means you have not
tried yet you well yet it means they're
locked I don't think it necessarily
means you can't open them okay let's
give it a whirl emblem of an of armour
okay good to know that yeah oh Lord
I mean I can get in here this door looks
like crap mm-hmm okay do you hope this
is happening this is a pretty it's gonna
be it's gonna be fine
yeah you're fine it's gonna be fine
shotgun what's that
so these are also battery pack they
don't show it in your inventory but you
have a stun gun so those work just like
daggers I didn't know that stun gun
zombies if they grab you I didn't even
know you could stun zombies that doesn't
even do they have like a electrocute
them I guess I mean I guess their nerves
are still intact so maybe that makes
sense like their nervous system works
yeah so don't try shooting that gun I
mean it won't do anything it's not gonna
kill you but yeah you don't want me to
try to shoot it well it's broken it's a
broken gas can I'd like to take that
care so finally the last episode
remember they're saying telling you how
to dispose of bodies yes you have to
burn them or you have to shoot off their
air dome but I don't have anything to
carry that kerosene with I need like a
or can something to light it with so you
will get something to lay it with an
something you carry all right can I go
up this ladder no all right I think
there's a book you can read on the table
if you feel like it maybe not or maybe
just open oh never mind different room
spoilers all right I don't think I think
so I might just kind of keep in mind
this is done you want to come back to if
you need fuel in the future oh is that a
minute fuel is that how that works it's
not permanent but there's a good amount
Anderson doesn't refill a few times so
wait where was that Oh coming from was
it coming from upstairs
I don't know maybe it something that
juror right here
I'm just messing with you oh yeah so
yeah ideally you would have something to
light and fuel so he wouldn't come up as
a crimson head as they're called I would
recommend just you'll probably be
upstairs for a little bit just like to
try to guide you I would say dump off
your ink ribbons should I save again or
do you think it's not working no no just
just get rid of them you'll need every
slot possible it's just you always
useful to never carry those around if
you can help it just keep an eye in this
situation though I understand it for
game mechanics but like in this
situation like I would a hundred percent
should I just get it rid of my shotgun
it's broken how much you want me to
guide you in this section I'm gonna keep
it yeah I don't want to I don't wanna
tell you what it's like y'all and I'm
gonna take it with you and yeah also I
keep this green herb just in case yeah
so right now you could take two hits
before dying if you take one hit you'll
be in danger if you take another one
you'll die I can only take two hits oh
no three cuz you're in caution right now
you're in the yellow
can I see yeah so you'll go down to red
and then you'll die shouldn't I just eat
this thing then umm no you might come
across a red herb which you when you
combine the two it fully heals you it's
kind of like I don't know if that saves
plant though because if it takes me
three hits to die well so if you go down
to red right now and then use the
regular green and only bring it back up
to yellow like one tear it's right
combine the red and the green it'll
bring you all back up to green
I would regular slight make sure you
don't take two hits successively without
healing yourself got it so run away yeah
all the time alright so there's the
ssambap here so you came from over down
that side no wait I killed that zombie
right but you came from so if you were
to go oh oh my god alright here we go
I think you theoretically could avoid
him if you want to but you can kill him
you got a decent minor rounds and it's
Auto and yet okay oh my god one hit kill
number two Sonya oh right no blood
oh man I don't think you're gonna get
him oh nice okay blood blood blood blood
let's see it lets see it
blood oh my god there you go you're good
okay so okay okay another thing which
this isn't useful right now but it will
be soon if there are two bodies next to
each other instead of using two separate
because the fuel I'll tell you later but
basically if you can get two bodies next
each other when they die that's really
good for burning purposes as you can
imagine that just burns both of them
with one like a canteen oh right because
they're next to each other have you
meant to do that that was actually
really good I do not mean to do that I
totally meant to do that I don't think
have I checked this area out yet no I
get confused with what I've seen
right so no according to this yeah hard
to explain I also just want you to
experience yourself but there are a
bunch of shortcuts within the mansion
that you'll become to love do they
logically make sense like within the
mansions schematics it know like if this
is my mansion in real life you'd be like
why the hell would they build it like
this they do sort of oh so if you ever
says you unlocked it that just means it
was locked that's one of the doors you
previously did and they said locked in
the other side you should recognize this
area oh yeah then we get there now I can
go through this one mm-hmm
so that's a shortcut between like
there's no blood on the ground
I remember killing that guy though so
yeah right now I'd say your priority is
to find like figure out a way to burn
bodies and also get the next key which
is the overarching okay well where is
this key over here oh my god I forget
where I am there's a there is a key hold
on a second
get ready to run left right now what
it's just left worried well [ __ ] right
sorry you tried to do them a purpose
sorry so this is one you don't need to
ever really kill him because he's on the
because I can always run left I was
getting confused at the other door
this is where I pushed over so yeah
right yeah so I will say just to guide
you a little bit you have not tried this
mansions you up huge you have not tried
as you could see you doors to the right
those red ones yeah okay I'll do that
hmm what yeah
this way the camera I am you're learning
more hands off no no it's honestly this
is my knowledge of maps so the pointy
arrow is where I'm currently facing is
that correct yeah there you go let me
double yeah all right I'm I got it all
right I understand I think I was
thinking that the arrow had no bearing
on my direction
oh [ __ ] I'm just prepping my where you
do this actually I'm gonna do something
like helpful it's not gonna see my thumb
go down remember that painting door
right here on the landing yeah this one
go yeah go through there I think just
like a little thing that you could pick
up now that'll save you some time later
I'm excited I feel like with your
guidance mm-hmm what was that noise
something like a rattlesnake there's
snakes in this game you have to tell me
they're they're very okay right there do
you see those back there there's shotgun
shells oh right because I have a shotgun
but it's broken
yes correct um I just want you to pick
these up because a lot of times there
have been times I forgot about these and
six shotgun shells the big deal
did they kill zombies in one-hitter
I'm sitting at what zombie you're
shooting so now just go back inside wait
what about this one member it's just
yeah so anytime it's locked neither side
the only way you can unlock is other
side it's like tough bugs alright so
yeah there are snakes in this game no I
think bigger kind of prominently in the
game but you'll see why snakes I hate
snakes
they're like awful I'm okay wait I
forget don't tell me I'll just have to
mentally come to terms you'll start
developing a mental landscape okay yeah
here we go
here we go run left I didn't think you
actually fall for that one isn't that
the worst when you can't see what you're
walking into
no I hate it I know what they're doing
with this there doesn't seem to be
anything useful here I also think the
reading is like spaced out almost to
upset you
there's nothing here but a bunch of
knickknacks I like to think that's how
slowly she actually reads she's just
stick to the stick to combat I have
severe anxiety right now honestly mm-hmm
you should Cheyennes examine this room
for yeah like I was saying no no just
try every door cuz like so if it is now
it's a sword key Dorrit you'll unlock it
before you have to walk through it and
then okay I'm just kind of this is a
cool cheat is once I go in this area I
see the whole layout of the room so I
know there's two left's here mm-hmm so
I'm gonna utilize that yeah check the
map as often as you need to
it's oh my god I don't trust anything in
this area Oh door it's like I don't feel
great I don't feel that oh my god okay I
I need that armor key mm-hmm oh my lord
someone really wanted the painting whoa
okay I wouldn't know I don't know I have
that plaque maybe I'm supposed to
combine them that seems reasonable
you're thinking along like the right
lines of you can feel the heat from your
loins oh my god heat why is there heat
it's like from the other side okay okay
there's one we're doing my hands are so
sweaty oh my god here we go you're so
easy right now stop all right yeah I
love knowing that this is actually
really calm room yet you have no idea
well I take the dog whistle walk okay
[ __ ] I'm full no no no okay so you're on
caution use the green herb okay wait I'm
what what the hell am i doing what is
this how did I get here
I didn't pick anything up did I I think
it was right next to the dog whistle
okay a crumpled memo today sir Spencer
told me to hide something where no one
could find it well I had this idea I
figured if I could somehow have it
protected by a dangerous animal like the
vicious canine that lives here no one
would be able to get near it as far as I
can tell the mutt is always hanging
around the second-floor balcony on the
west side of the terrace I was very
specific he ought to come running at the
sound of a dog whistle oh God
this is where you come in the thing is I
reckon you're the only person that can
get near that damn dog without risking a
serious mauling which means only you can
put this collar on him that the object
that sir Spencer wants hidden is
concealed inside you are the oh my gosh
you're the only person I can trust at
this of course you'll get something out
of it as well remember that certain item
that you've always wanted to get ahold
of well in exchange for your services I
might just be able to get it for you
this could
work out well for both of us who's John
Tolman I don't know just a management
worker that's a pretty like Joycean
stream of thought journal entry like he
detailed that everything he was thinking
yeah he's been really helpful oh yeah
okay great so thank God that combines
cuz I'm out of stuff here yeah I would
recommend save no no use a combine you
have another couple items coming up well
I don't
oh right here's your caution just use
that you're saying use it so that I can
open up a slot because I got more I
didn't you're on Koch in anyway you'll
find more herbs you'll be fine I
understand you are fine literally it was
literally fine I mean I don't even know
how you would do this with six slots you
have to really think out so Chris can
take more damage and hasn't get but he
doesn't get the same weapons as Jill and
he also yeah okay this is where I learn
how to combine herbs in this book will
Sam will sample three herbs green herb
is physical strength Blue is toxins so
that's important to know and the red
herb has no real effect by itself
oh okay so they actually it has no
function at all but mixing the green in
red
it has bonus got it we will outline the
effects of red herbs when mixed with
other herbs when we have more data okay
I wonder what red and blue do okay oh
but I still need to be able to maneuver
lighter fluid onto them yes we just we
pretty much passed it so yeah I know it
is an open journal alright that's it
I'm just double-checking and making sure
we did not pass it you'll get that sir I
just want to make sure I'm not missing
anything
that's historical figures is probably a
better way to say that Oh people's like
cultures maybe various peoples of the
earth
Chicagoans San Franciscans knew yokas
Ohioans it's not really earth is just
America Raccoon City is what Midwestern
city I have no idea I didn't know they
ever actually clarified where it was
they do later on I think is just big
Midwest so you know where resonable two
takes but is it like Springfield where
like in the Simpsons okay wait okay here
we go here we go here we go oh my god
die oh yeah is gone we're about burning
that son of a [ __ ] how did I get a head
shot it's just it's like a critical hit
but well no actually like if you're
close enough to them and you aim up and
with like a shotgun it's a lot more
likely if you doing the inventory of
pauses are you sure cuz I heard it ooh
you'll still hear the noises but yeah
okay um I would say keep exploring this
hallway but the area you really want to
go to is down there soon enough stairs
so now if you recall remember that art
room where you got the first dagger and
that you push that okay and you push the
dresser up into the statue to eat the
map yep there was that locked door so
you were not able to get into the first
floor East Wing until now so they're
just stairs down their armor all armor
oh I don't like it oh god I don't want
to die I don't want to I have so much
stuff that I've collected I don't wanna
start over oh man alright that's the
last time
nobody has to play this oh you're an ass
it's the complete opposite of dangerous
oh okay okay I'm gonna tell you how to
do this because fireplace I'll let you
yeah won't you let me sorry
yeah do it oh I can light the fire with
my fireplace noise I don't need you
couldn't light a fire alright so well it
did something shut up on my inventory is
full like anti-gay lines carved into the
relief glow red the relief
what's a relief
they talking about that map yeah is this
important
yeah oh [ __ ] it's kind of an opaque
puzzle yeah that's the only reason I was
gonna tell you how to do it because
allow you don't need to I'll just tell
you use the wooden mount on the relief
and you'll burn the right that's smart
I'm sure you could have figured out by
yourself like and now you'll you won't
have the wooden mount in your inventory
which is good but so I need that to have
the map yes collect it again that's
pretty smart so now I just it's also it
just becomes a map it doesn't become an
item right so you got rid of the wooden
mount it's just part of cool well excuse
me I still can't combine dem herbs do
you know I mean what do you mean I can't
combine the herbs because I only have
one slot all right yeah you know these
verbs are gonna disappear they'll be
here still just remember this room okay
so I have this room and there's door
that haven't gone in yet
so I should probably do that mm-hmm it's
locked so if you don't if it's this or
key you'll be able to get through a bit
if it's anything else then okay oh you
know what I'm so dumb I didn't even
realize that it says it's green if I've
like gotten everything in it and it's
red if there's stuff still to do that's
pretty cool I didn't even see that all
right here we go is it armor okay that
serves me right for making fun of the
game I want to save I have anxiety okay
I feel like I don't want to lose any of
these items do you feel like I've
progressed enough where I should be able
to save I'm just worried if I go a
little I would say like wait until the
end of the episode but I've done like so
much oh well you you've gotten some
progress but keep in mind like you're
not you're gonna be doing it faster next
time if like say if you did die now and
you had to redo it you would do it
faster you know where there zombies are
you know where you're going so this
store is not
open a bowl right okay so I need to go
downstairs there's a zombie down here
I heard him right yeah oh I heard you
okay so see him can i I would say you
couldn't avoid can I shoot this
chandelier and make it fall on his head
yeah wish that'd be sweet I know okay
wait what so I would say you could avoid
him you've got enough space to go in
that door
wait how do you know I want to go into a
door you timeout this it's unlocked
there's two unlock doors I'm just saying
there's so there's two okay so okay so
that's leading to a room theoretically
if you want to explore this whole area
before you go through that door which
leads to three more just check you want
to check out that door which this one
that leads into the room not the hallway
yes right I understand but that's the
more dangerous one to get around him
yeah but I mean he could because it's
that door the one behind the chandelier
kill him if you want
oh no I've [ __ ] upset him what do I
do
just know I can't get around him well
before he moves you could have what who
makes these calls if you go back through
one of these doors he'll reset him why
don't I just shook him or shoot him yeah
can I do Kim it would have been easier
down there let me shoot him oh my god
you should be good all right and then
just I would kill him okay so wait you
don't go in no killing me I'll kill him
because if you would gone through the
door what every set is healthy would
have wasted those oh I didn't know that
yeah so once you is he dead once you
commit I wouldn't here's the thing
actually okay get up you [ __ ] I see
blood okay but also if they are down and
they'll do this thing where they grab at
you and she like curb stomps them and
gets the headshot it's actually
sometimes worth it to go down a little
bit in health if you were green if that
makes sense because you'll headshot them
with your foot and they won't be come
back as a crimson head later on these
are advanced techniques I'm looking for
like how to just live
I feel like you're I'm a long-run kind
of person you got to be in this game I'm
not speedrunning this oh no this is okay
sweet here we go Oh ha
there is ace okay okay more kerosene
great whoo I can save me gimme gimme
gimme a man put kerosene in there boom
all right now you can start burning body
something honest videos that looks like
a a whiskey flask flask for liquor
so wait okay so I'm gonna burn all these
[ __ ] body you know that's a way yeah
what I mean you're in a safe room you
can dump off a few items if you want
before you come out and start burning I
I completely agree with you just go burn
some bodies okay
sweet just hope he doesn't come back
shut up he could come back as a crimson
head right now oh my god where is he
he's right where you left him okay all
right so wait make sure you're standing
over him then okay good to know
these are things Oh God okay here we go
um what - mmm that's such [ __ ] honestly
all right good
all right so use it mm-hmm back up
Oh is he gonna light on fire cool so he
will not come back as a crimson head no
our crimson heads stronger faster and
stronger they are very fast they like
they it's like a jog instead of a lilt
okay it's not a lurch anymore it's more
of a I was just gonna refill my canteen
now because I'm already here
mm-hmm doesn't that seem reasonable yeah
makes sense yeah I'd say at this point
I'd keep it canteen with you I'm
actually not sure the rules whether like
it still takes us a monic fuel if you
refill one or two but oh right that's I
think I think welcome every you also
have more fuel back in that room where
you just light them on fire when they're
alive that seems plausible wish we owe
my god okay don't say okay when I get to
new areas no going to inventory
alright I'm gonna I'm gonna just just in
the interest of getting rid of items I
just realized were the last sword key
doors but we're not near it I would dump
a couple items off before you go into
this area Oh cuz I'm gonna get stuff I
understand um alright so I'll go in here
is my third time in here I can't use
that shotguns alright unless there's
like a boss coming up or something I
feel it wait okay there also there a
couple items in that box oh I gotta pay
more attention all right so I'm we're
not near it so I can get rid of this key
there oh um no bring it in case I could
be wrong I know where our sword Kia
doors and try remember if there's
another one but I'm what can I dump I
can't dump any do you want me to like
tell you what to bring what not to bring
they need all this stuff I feel like I
don't need is the shotgun dump the dog
whistle for now his memory do you
remember the area they said you'll need
that where the dog is
yes Terrace okay second floor North
Terrace I would also something dump the
shotgun shells but I those would be
useful for late for later but I wouldn't
bring him now and who are very why and I
would actually tell you to save right
now I normally wouldn't but there's
stuff coming up that if it's the first
time playing the game you might be and
I'm dumb
try not to guide you too much but I'm
also trying to like I would like to save
I don't feel good okay yeah go for it
you'll find ample egg ribbons so an
abundance of it I I don't feel good I
would like to say oK we've done so much
ja mm-hmm
how are we doing on time you've only
been going like 30 minutes it really
feels like so much longer but I think
it's because you keep scaring me
I mean I'll mess up would it be if a
zombie popped out of your safe room ah
stop it
so I'm gonna put the in Krieger pins
back that gives me two spaces that
should be good that seems reasonable now
do I need sorry do I need the lighter
and the oil if I'm going to a new area
because there's not gonna be bodies yet
but you probably want me to burn them
when I'm there yeah I would say bring it
any chance you get to eliminate a
crimson head down the road is pretty
there's so many bodies upstairs though
should I just take them out now before
there's a useful shortcut coming up I
would encourage you to utilize okay I'm
just listening turn your cargo pants she
looks good
you know star stands for mmm-hmm wait
special yeah tactical tactics special
tactics oh it says it underneath this is
good I'm trying to read it it's hard
and special tactics and Rescue Squad
damn I was gonna say that I was trying
to read it oh I wonder let you figure
this one out
so I wonder if that means it's gonna
break and I won't be able to go back out
interesting Mary no you should not have
done that
why uh these are no you just went back
to the same to her great I wanted to see
if I can go back oh can I only use this
door so many times yeah you did just
save I'm wondering if we should reload
is that no let's roll with it let's roll
with it no I don't know you're okay you
can only use it three times whether the
point is the second okay you can only
come through this way twice or three
times so this is the second time go back
through just keep that in mind next time
you can only use this door from this
room to the next I did not know that was
your thought process but of course it's
myself that's all right these are the
lessons you have oh my god don't go back
through that door I'm not it stop
yelling at me
am I going through this door wait let's
check them out okay so I just went
through that door which I'm not allowed
to go through anymore mm-hmm I'm at a
door now and there's also oh my god
there's three doors and other doors in
this hallway so this is a very important
hallway mhm
well I feel like I should just go
through oh wait well Kimani the one get
rid of your soar key so definitely try
the lock doors in case those are the
last one how do I know if they're luck
they're just the red red yeah
well raise I'm like my arrow is over the
whether or not this is red oh yeah so
that's not like so you want me to go in
this room try it will at least try them
out cuz if they are sore key doors old
this one looks like it's a lion key
mm-hmm
oh god okay alright there's a [ __ ]
zombie in here show yourself show
yourself is he around the corner dodj I
can't sleep
no what yeah you were so mean oh through
the door yeah
no no don't go through there just keep
shooting him just nice good job nice
good movement but yeah how can I see him
okay but so I would light him on fire
some sick maneuvering great oh wait I
gotta stand over his body I got it okay
got it you're actually good on handgun
ammo you'll find a lot of anga suck it
bathed in the fire oh my god like so
stressful all right you good though
that's that's really good you don't
don't worry too much about this hallway
so this is the other now shut up oh my
god alright here's the other one here we
go okay armor okay more armor
got it mm-hmm okay so I can't use my key
not a surgeon No so I have a hallway
that I've already passed that goes to
the right and I have a hallway that goes
to another hallway that leads to a
staircase oh and a red door so I could
try that one first which one the one
that goes along that red door this one
looks stressful you check it out oh god
but why is it so dark in here
I love it sound effects of different
doors it's a pretty mean rusty okay this
is outdoors mm-hmm I didn't know that
are you a dog person or capper shut up
there's dogs out here aren't there he's
[ __ ] I'm a dog person I have a dog
he's adorable he's a little french
bulldog he would never hurt anyone did
you hear that I think I was clearing my
throat no there was a growl who's in
there
Oh No
mash button can I kill him oh my [ __ ]
god can I shoot him just can I not shoot
dogs you can the shotguns pretty useful
for them oh my god I didn't go through
the door I don't okay so I don't know if
you saw did you see down the hall
there's like a a weird little panel next
to it yeah that's not a normal key that
you have right now just in the interest
of that dog not mauling you you can't do
anything down there yeah I'm almost dead
your caution you're good you're good
keep using those Jukes and you'll be
fine Duke
thank you mine you just saved like now
you could have now you know what's doors
you don't even need to try you could get
back to that point like in like 10
seconds no I can't because I can only
use that door one more times yeah but if
you died in your recent in the safe room
that negates the two times you used it
so you haven't used it like it what
actually might be beneficial long run if
you died right now but we're not gonna
do that though we're gonna be survivors
okay okay so there's a door in front of
me there's a long hallway and there's a
locked door with a dotted room what's
that all about
that's interesting great so do you mean
to try the locked door first or you want
to try every door as it come to it I
would say just comb the area
oh my gosh stop it wait what the [ __ ]
kind of room is this it's like the
umbrella logo on the floor looks like
the the walls at my pediatricians office
when I was younger this little mansion
reminds me of my doctor's office really
hard even know that's the same door okay
honestly like how would you even know
that doctor Purnima was my doctor I
don't care fine I'll leave my background
stories your doctor ones suite there's a
dagger there's ink ribbons mutual stuff
so this room is good room mm-hmm
are there ever bad things in good things
room as a zombie ever popped out of your
from under your coffee table in real
life geez when you take the dagger yes
can I max out on daggers oh [ __ ] wait
why it's nothing stop
looks like someone to slash the couch it
does look like that doesn't it let me
sick of a zombie just messing with you
popped out the couch stop ooh can I
light this the clock there's a fireplace
yeah do it up
I just don't know if I can't wait an
accurate yeah do it I'm just kidding I'm
[ __ ] with you it's not necessary you
can do it there are traces of something
burnt here I don't know what it's trying
to tell me there's nothing of interest
here I like that that's nice that really
helps convey how don't burnt their house
they check out the artwork in the room
I'm a oh mama wait shucks wait why do I
have this broken one don't tell me oh no
I don't want oh wait I can put my new
shotgun can I put the old one on there
yeah so let me ask do the triangle thing
and then let me ask you this cuz I feel
like I'm doing this mmm because it's
guiding me is this opening up a door
you've done it that's what I think I'm
doing do you I mean no member because it
looks like if I didn't do that
the hinge is off you're good I'm just
curious
remember you don't have to give it away
okay I'm gonna ask you questions all the
time you don't have to answer them I
will say that you just avoided a death
cool like doesn't it strike you as odd
that they're just weird like interior
room right here basically it was like an
in the Indiana Jones if you would left
the room without replacing the weight it
would have crushed you from the ceiling
Oh feeling would lower on this room yes
so when you walked in here if there was
not a shotgun weight balancing so that's
why the ceilings are also really high
and who's wondering what this room was
that makes so much sense if you didn't
make me keep that broken show yeah I
wouldn't have I would not have put that
together like I would have just I would
have just gone yeah
so now you the shotgun which is good Oh
should I equip it no not yeah you only
have like 12 total shells so I mean you
could but it'll I would say if your
shotgun shells has a word of advice
oh I'll help you through
okay okay so I need to take a right okay
here we go
what's my health like are you on cushon
I could only get hit once twice you go
down to danger first and then you die
right so I can get hit once and then I
die get hit once and then you're you
could still keep moving around but then
you died break excellent yeah this this
was like a bad area
this is Jill's bedroom where she goes to
break bottles and be angry excuse me so
there's a door up coming to my left
okay what's your inventory looking like
Shh oh my god sorry I'm just talking I
know I'm just okay you're good I'm just
scared that's all sorry I should be able
to go to this door which I'm going to do
the story looks like [ __ ] yeah it does
OOP it's a fan don't worry it's a fan
I'm listening for zombies if anyone's
wondering what I'm doing do you wanna
brush your teeth thank you they just
water dirty water that bath mat is
soaked in blood though pending like a
chain attached to the plug or they
implying you have to reach into the
water and unplug it
yeah I I didn't think that through
when's the cutscene over that's one ugly
rubber duck let me play okay cool she
took care of it
good job that's why you're a stars agent
boy vond
deputy Bob Adia came at the zappity all
right well I'm gonna burn that guy right
now [ __ ] yeah you are actually
yeah do it I don't care what no no no
you do it he's gonna say cuz you're
probably not gonna come back in here but
Dom bees can go through doors sometimes
so he might become a problem later so
that was good this week all you know I
mean because a lot of it is measuring
whether you think he'll come back
through an area so if you're just gonna
avoid him anyway then don't waste the
fuel but he could have he could always
come back to the door you've got a
healthy supply of defensive items which
is good cuz that at a certain point you
might even want to start opting for
those instead of using handgun ammo but
right now your handgun a most good as
well all right so those it I came in
here for a dagger right can I look at
myself in the mirror can I brush my
teeth
not if you're a vampire there's a weird
twist
vampires vs. zombies alright sorry I'm
trying to get my bearings so I'm gonna
leave this door I'm gonna take a left
mmm there's a lock door and then there's
a non lock door okay here we go nervous
okay so this is the locked door
according to my map which I can totally
read oh I used my lockpick so what do
you do if you're not her she's dealing
with the lockpick right correct
tells Chris to think you pick it up
later on yeah cuz the probably recall
Chris starts with the lighter whereas
Jill just not oh my god there's dogs in
here names maybes not and mobs let's
chip I'm out it's in progress but
there's nowhere to go
do I have any um okay I have no ABS so I
can only take one hit this is dangerous
all right all right all right what if
there was something important in there
um
can I shoot the dog I can shoot the dog
yeah should I change my shotgun and
shoot the dog in the face I would just
dodged the dog because it is possible or
switched I can dodge dogs yeah I mean
they're so fast there's this like period
when before they attack if you're fast
enough oh yeah equip your shotgun in
case you do have a decent amount of
shells although I would keep that as a
last resort but you could dodge there is
something important I hear that it would
help to get right now but I can't dodge
and get something is that right yeah
reason just cuz I have to get the item
and I have to dodge the dog think that
sounds hard [ __ ] wait okay hold on I'm
just trying to think whether yeah just
if you see a dog kill him because if you
do thinking ahead kill the dog kill the
dog if there is a dog there my night
there is a dog I heard it was he
scampering he was barking at me he
fluttering across the ground supposed
moths die [ __ ]
dodo dodo dodo dodo
I hear him oh oh he's right there he's
not a nuisance he's not a problem right
now can I shoot him through the thing
don't waste ammo like that what I would
must he's a threat don't shoot him I
mean he's a threat but he's not Oh
oh my god that's so scary
oh [ __ ] yeah do that okay so alright
shoot it wait wait okay get ready
wait till I die
I can't no one's happy oh my god I need
a plan
yeah yourself an impasse I would go for
the plant heal yourself and then just
get ready might be dead and then use
that [ __ ] right now you're the red I
hear him unfortunately you don't have
enough room wait hold on go back to your
inventory [ __ ] those think ribbons are
[ __ ] you over can I can I drop them
no wait no do i discard them if I don't
use them no you can't even just garden
you have to put him in a safe room
that's one of the yeah one of the the
key is also messing up I know it's
archaea all right why don't I [ __ ]
kill the judge no just use that green
herb but there's red plants right there
let me just kill this dog you could
already be dead
no I'm saying there's he's right there
on the ground you can see his body
there's no way for you to know can I
burn
dog when I burn this dog don't worry
don't burn the dog why they just don't
come back don't worry about it
how did he get in here use that green
herb you'll find plenty more just use
that one how did he get in here answer
me he's that yeah use that okay so
you're good on you're good on how you
can cook it out you'll be back through
this corridor again so you can you can
say those so how did he get in are they
jumping the fence so pick up that bag
just get that bag it's a key item for
later
what do you mean this bag chemical to
use on plants as a literal name I don't
I don't feel good about okay you're
almost you're almost in the clear where
did that freaking dog come from you a
lot of defensive items you're here but I
can't take very many hits here whew this
is an interesting camera angle here's my
advice to you for the net until you get
to another safe room don't waste say
more shotgun shells just use like
movement and dodge no not even a gun I'm
not saying that I'm just saying like no
just run how do we all right let me let
me clear my honestly don't even know
what's how do I use my stun thing those
are automatic the build if you just want
me to run around dodging cuz I say if
that's the case I'm not saying
everything honest I don't know what's
about to happen it's like it's when they
it's certain like we need so I said yeah
that's what we're kind of going to save
remember in order to save right now and
that last day from you would have had to
use that door knob again which you don't
want to use no no no no I don't like
this this is a long hallway okay but see
okay so down here you remember this room
that you went in that's where you got
the first dagger that's a huge shortcut
if you get down to that
but you said if I get down to it I'm
said you'll get down to it so this is
like a juice thing is these is he reset
does he go back in the window no then
when I was broken I would say just
dodgem you'll be able to do I'm telling
you just like weave
I'm not a weaver oh my god do it just
run up for it nice nice you got it yeah
yeah yeah going yeah you're good you're
good you're good there you go
sore key is almost out of your inventory
too so that's a huge shortcut now you'll
recognize where you are but I there's a
dog in there there would have been two
if you didn't kill that other one on the
terrace so you actually kind of made a
little easier wait it wasn't there a guy
in here that killed once mm-hmm in there
this is where you got the first floor
map up in this urn right I guess what
I'm saying is is is there a body in here
that could become a red guy it wouldn't
matter that's why you pushed remember I
told you post the dresser dresser back
and from the door last night like I need
a break all right so so you me so you're
right near the main hall do I want to go
back to the main home typewriter in the
dining room if you want to save right so
you're saying I should go across the
main hall here yeah because you know
this area is safe now okay or is it shot
kidding it's oh my god you're good
you're like Lamaze breathing before
every encounter is all this effective it
seems no good news other than I'm still
alive in this madhouse
no I can't say it's much safer here
either
we'd better secure our escape route
first it's gotta be a back door
somewhere where the hell have you
written let's split up again
see you later watch out bad plan very oh
you [ __ ] up didn't you no I'm gonna
I'll tell you later
I'm gonna save what's wrong why do you
do that
nothing you've come to terms with
something bad no no it's nothing like
huge you're good
alright I'm saving - my name is anything
shut up there you go
is this that our episode it's how long
has it been about an hour
alright let's do it a little less is it
good it's a good good
you got angry I'm so stressed out like
you're supposed to be that was that's
the iconic the the dog through the
window is the iconic jump scare one of
them I would say the dog biting me in
the butt when I was outside is the most
iconic thing that's happened to me yeah
I thought it took a chunk out of your
cheeks
yikes alright well that was it for this
episode of resident can evil stick
around folks we are going to be doing
another one pretty soon find the epic
conclusion no you're not gonna finish
conclusion gonna beat the game the
conclusion of Resident Evil 1 the kiss
clusion
we'll see you guys in the next episode
thanks for watching
Oh